you mentioned
smart contracts what are your thoughts
about
in the context of the history of money
about ethereum about smart contracts
about kind of
uh
more systematic at scale formalization
of agreements between humans
i think
it must be the case
that a lot of the complexity in a
mortgage
is
redundant
that when we are confronted with pages
and pages and pages and pages of small
print
uh we're seeing some
manifestation of of the late stage
regulatory state
the transaction itself is quite simple
and most of the verbage is just ass
covering by regulators
so i think the smart contract
although i'm sure lawyers will
email me and tell me i'm wrong
can deal with a lot of the plain vanilla
and maybe not so plain transactions that
we want to do
and eliminate yet more
intermediaries
that's my
my kind of working assumption and
given that a lot of
of financial transactions
have the potential at least to be
to be simplified automated
turned into smart contracts that that's
probably where the future goes
i can't see an obvious reason why my
range of different financial
needs let's think about insurance for
example
will continue to be met
with
instruments that in some ways are 100
years old
so i think we're still
an early stage of a financial revolution
that will greatly streamline
how we take care of
all those financial needs that we have
uh mortgages and insurance leave leap to
mind you know most households are
are penalized for
being financially poorly educated and
confronted with oligopolistic
financial services providers so you kind
of leave
college already in debt
so you start
uh
in debt servitude and then
you got to somehow leave her up to buy a
home if you can because everybody's kind
of telling you you should do that so
so you and your spouse you are getting
even more leveraged and you're
you're long one asset class called real
estate which is super illiquid
i mean already i'm
i'm crying inside at the thought of
describing so many households financial
predicament in that way and i'm not done
with them yet because oh by the way
there's all this insurance you have to
take out and here are the providers that
are willing to insure you and here are
the premiums you're going to be paying
which are kind of presented to you
that's your that's your car insurance
that's your home insurance and if you're
here it's the earthquake insurance and
pretty soon you're just bleeding money
in a bunch of monthly payments to the
mortgage
lender to the insurer
to all the other people that lent you
money
and let's look at your balance sheet it
sucks
you know there's this great big chunk of
real estate and what else have you
really got on there
and the other side is a bunch of debt
which is probably paying too high
interest
the typical household in the median
kind of range is is at the mercy of
oligopolistic financial services
providers go down further in the social
scale and people are outside the
financial system all together and those
poor folks have to rely on
bank notes and informal lending with
huge punitive rates
we have to do better than this this has
to be
this has to be improved upon and i think
what's exciting about our time is that
technology now exists that didn't exist
when i wrote the ascent of money to
solve these problems when i wrote this
end of money which is in 2008
you couldn't really solve
the problem i've just described
certainly you couldn't solve with
something like micro finance that was
obviously not
viable that
interest rates were high the transaction
costs were crazy but now we have
solutions and these solutions are
extremely exciting so fintech is this
great force for good that brings people
into the financial system
and reduces transaction costs crypto's
part of it but it's just part of it
there's a much broader story of fintech
going on here where
you get suddenly you get financial
services on your phone don't cost nearly
as much as they they did when there had
to be a bricks and mortar building on
main street that you kind of went humbly
and beseeched to lend you money i'm
excited about that because it seems to
me very socially transformative
i'll give you one other example of
what's great
the people who really get scalped in our
financial system are senders and
receivers of
remittances
which are often amongst the poorest
families in the world the people who are
like my wife's family in east africa
really kind of hand-to-mouth
and if you send money to east africa or
the philippines or central america it's
it's the transaction costs are awful
uh
i'm talking to you western union
we're gonna solve that problem
so 10 years from now the transaction
costs will just be negligible and the
money will go to the people who need it
rather than to rent seeking financial
institutions so i'm on the side of the
revolution with this because
i think the incumbent financial
institutions globally are doing a pretty
terrible job
and
middle class and lower class families
lose out and
thankfully technology technology allows
us to fix this yeah so fintech can
remove a lot of inefficiencies in the
system i'm super excited myself maybe as
a machine learning person in the data
oracles so
converting a lot of our physical world
into data so
and have smart contracts on top of that
so
that no longer is there's this fuzziness
about what is the concrete nature of the
agreements you can tie your agreement to
weather you can tie your agreement to
the behavior of
certain kinds of financial
systems you can tie your behavior to
i don't know uh i mean all kinds of
things you can connect it to the body in
terms of human um
sensory information like uh you can make
an agreement that if you
don't lose five pounds in the next month
you're going to pay me a thousand
dollars or something like that i don't
know it's a stupid example but it's not
because like you can create all kinds of
services on top of that you can you can
just create all kinds of interesting
applications that completely
revolutionize
how humans transact
i think
of course
we don't want to
create a world of
chinese style social credit
in which our behavior
becomes so transparent uh to
providers of financial services
particularly insurers that
uh
when i try to go into the pub i'm i'm
stopped from doing so
every time you take a drink your
insurance goes up
right or my credit card won't work uh in
certain restaurants because they serve
you know ribeye steak
i fear that world because i see it being
built in china and
we we must at all costs make sure that
the western world has something
distinctive to offer
uh it can't just be oh it's the same as
in china only the day to go to
to five tech companies rather than to
xi jinping so
i think the the way we need to steer
this world is
in the way that
our
data
are by default vaulted on our devices
and we choose
when to release the data yes
rather than the default setting being
that the data are available
that's important i think because it was
one of the biggest mistakes of
the evolution of the internet that that
in a way the default was to let our our
data be plundered it's hard to undo that
but i think we can we can at least
create a new regime
that in future makes privacy default
rather than
open access default
you